- [Narrator] There's no Chinese alphabet.
Instead, each word is represented
by a symbol or character.
(air whooshing)
- How on Earth did a language
with tens of thousands
of characters fit onto this keyboard?
- [Narrator] Here is a
world of communication,
tailored for your needs
of today and tomorrow.
- [Narrator] What really accounts
for China's meteoric rise
as a major global power?
- This is Shenzhen.
It's a city in the south of China.
I've actually been there.
But back in the 1980s,
this was just a sleepy fishing village
with less than, like 100,000 people.
Today, it is home to 12.5 million people,
a giant metropolis with huge buildings
and home to some of the
largest tech companies
on the planet.
This city is emblematic of
China's technological rise
over the last 40 years.
It's an explosion in
technology and development
that has really never happened
before in human history.
From an agrarian society to
a technological powerhouse
in just a couple of decades.
- That's fast.
- This almost didn't happen.
China almost didn't become
the technological powerhouse.
And what held them back is something
I have thought about a lot,
which is this keyboard.
This keyboard has like, 80 or so keys,
and the Chinese language has like
tens of thousands of characters.
So how did they fit their
language onto this keyboard?
To answer that question,
you have to dive deep into modern China,
into Chairman Mao,
into the divide between
Taiwan and mainland China,
who despite speaking the same language
use very different typing methods,
all because of geopolitics.
It's a story of how China took a keyboard
that was developed for a vastly
different language system
and mastered it, mastered it better
than we did here in the West.
It's a fascinating story
of culture and history
and technology, and I
want to share it with you.
- [Narrator] Here is China.
- [Narrator] It's become a keystone
of national economic policy.
- [Narrator] A large part
of China's population
lives in large cities.
- [Narrator] I really
don't quite understand
everything that's happening.
(upbeat music)
- To understand how Chinese
speakers type on a keyboard
like this, I talk to my friend Mangle Kuo,
who's currently in quarantine in Taiwan.
- I just came back and quarantine
in Taiwan's quarantine hotel.
- Oh, my gosh. Wow.
Mangle has lived in both China and Taiwan.
He's technologically savvy
and helped me understand
how people type, not
just on their keyboard
but on their phone.
- So basically growing up
as a Chinese or Taiwanese,
you have to learn how to
write those characters.
That's kind of the first thing first.
And then you learn the, like
the pronunciation system
behind all the characters.
And in China, that's pinyin,
and in Taiwan, that's zhuyin.
- So let's break this down.
Most languages are
written with an alphabet.
Each letter in that
alphabet represents a sound.
And when you string those sounds
together, you make a word.
It seems so intuitive as if like
this is the only way to do it.
But in Chinese,
- There's another way.
- Chinese uses complex
characters for each word,
so every word is a character.
Each one of these characters
represents a different thing,
an object, the feeling, a concept, a verb.
All in all, there're
upwards of 70 or 80 thousand
of these characters.
This system was just fine.
It worked in China for a really long time
because you can use a brush
or a pen to write stuff out.
- I like that. It's like if
it ain't broke, don't fix it.
- This is the qwerty keyboard.
It's called the qwerty keyboard
because I mean, just look at it.
This is the mechanism to which
people not just communicate
with each other, but code the world,
the software and programs
that we all use all the time.
When this started to take
over, China had a real problem.
Listen, I need to just pause
to tell you about something
which is that investing
money is hard, sometimes.
And honestly, I'm like in my
30s now and I just sort of
learning the art of
investing and not really.
The sponsor of today's video
is the company called Acorns.
What they do is they allow you
to get started with investing
with really small amounts
of money to begin with.
And they make it so that you
can take your spare change
from any transaction and
automatically invest it
in the background.
So as you go about your day,
like spending money on things
it automatically invest
into diversified portfolios
that experts manage, so that
you can actually start building
an investment portfolio
like in the background
and without a ton of money.
It's an app that allows
this all happen very easily.
Acorns is a financial awareness
app that makes it easy
to save and invest every day
in the background of like,
starting with just spare
change, no expertise required.
You can set up an Acorns
account in like three minutes
and start with just five dollars.
You don't need a giant chunk
of cash to start investing.
And it's not just investing.
You can also set up your
personal check-in account
and your retirement
account all in this one app
that you have access to.
You get this heavy metal
debit card that is the card
that when you swipe and it
rounds up every transaction
and invest those cents
into your portfolio.
You can even get it customer engraved
so you have a suite debit
card that works by the way,
at tens of thousands of ATM
machines around the country
with no fees. It's a
pretty darn good deal.
So there's a link at my description.
It's accorns.com/johnnyharris.
Clicking that link, help
support that channel.
But it also gives you a
10-dollar bonus investment
when you sign up.
So you can sign up and
start having 10 dollars
in your portfolio.
Overall, I believe in
starting early with investing
and Acorns is a fantastic
way to get started
with minimal effort and not a
ton of money to get started.
But you can just do it in the background.
It's a fantastic way.
So thank Acorns for sponsoring this video.
Let's get back to the story.
They had to figure out
how to fit this onto this,
and fast, because the world of computing
started to explode in the
70s, and 80s, and 90s.
- Hello, I'm Bill Gates.
- Here in the United
States, the qwerty keyboard
was a very natural tool.
We were able to use our
alphabet and our symbols
that we all are very used to,
to develop programming languages
so that we can make software.
And soon, more and more
computers were showing up
into American homes.
(pop songs from the '80s)
- [Narrator] The Commodore
64 now in a family pack.
- Meanwhile on the other
side of the planet,
China, a country of
almost a billion people
only had 3000 computers
in the entire country.
They were so far behind the West
when it came to computer literacy.
The Chinese government
begins to freak out.
And it's like, guys we're
getting absolutely destroyed
by the West because of
this whole computer thing,
and you're telling me that
is because we can't fit
our language onto this keyboard?
Are you kidding me? What
we're gonna do about it?
So the Chinese government
made this a huge priority.
And they finally started to
develop somethings that worked.
(door opening)
- I got it.
(audience laughing)
- The first major system of
typing used the qwerty keyboard
to build the shape of the characters.
- We call it Cangjie.
- Cangjie, and it was
pretty darn complicated.
- It's basically like, puzzles.
- Like Legos.
- Yeah, kind of, like a brick.
You just put them together.
I can write basic characters using that.
- The system was clever
but it was complicated
and not very fast at first.
Luckily, China had a
wild card up its sleeve
that will help get Chinese speakers
typing on a qwerty keyboard.
It had to do with this guy, Chairman Mao.
- [Narrator] The great
Chinese Chairman Mao Zedong.
- History time, here we go.
- [Narrator] The Communist
Party's propaganda machine
portrays the Chairman's Great Leap Forward
as a dazzling success.
- Mao was really bullish
about modernizing China.
And one of his pet project was scrapping
the entire Chinese character
system and replacing it
with a Western-style alphabet
that sounds out Chinese words,
sort of like how we sound out our English
or Italian or Spanish words.
Now it was like learning
thousands of Chinese characters
is hard and complicated so
why don't we just have a Latin
or Romanized alphabet like
the rest of the world.
So by 1949, Mao was like ready
to roll, scrapping the entire
Chinese writing system in
the name of a Roman alphabet.
But then, one of its close buddies,
former Communist dictator
Joseph Stalin, convinced Mao
not to totally kill off
the Chinese characters.
Stalin was like, dude, don't,
dude you're gonna regret it.
And Mao was like, fine.
So he kept the Chinese characters
as the main writing system
but for teaching literacy in
school, he developed a written
alphabet called pinyin.
- Pinyin, P-I-N-Y-I-N.
- Where you can use the Roman letters
to spell out Chinese words
by the way that they sound.
So right now you're
typing out this sentence
in Romanized charcters in the way
that it would be
phonetically spelt in Roman,
like "wo" is W-O, right?
- Yes.
- Okay. So you typed it all out,
- Yeah.
- and down there it renders it, okay. Wow.
So now if you want to
write the word "beef",
which is "niu-rou".
- How to say "beef"?
- I think "niu-rou".
- "NIU-ROU"
- I've no idea, "niu-rou", "niu".
- "R-rao, niu-rao". I've no idea.
Instead of memorizing these
characters which means "beef",
you can just spell it
out by the way it sounds.
This romanization of Chinese,
again it's called pinyin
would become really helpful years later
when the Chinese government
is trying to figure out
how to get people to type
on Western computers.
But wait a minute.
We can't go on before we mention
a little bit of geopolitics.
(canon firing)
Okay, it's 1940s.
Mao and his Communist
revolutionaries are taking over
mainland China in a bloody
revolution and civil war.
And the Chinese government
that they overthrow
and are fighting with, end
up losing and retreating to
an island nearby called
Taiwan to continue with
their non-Communist version of China.
And they both think that
they're the real China
and they start this war
that has never stopped
and they're still fighting this war
and they both think they're China.
Anyway, that's absolutely
a story I want to tell
but I'm not going there.
Now again blinders, we're
talking about qwerty keyboards.
- If we're trying to figure something out,
now we need to focus, okay?
- So you have this "two
Chinas", the Communist one,
and the non-Communist one.
Mao is pushing the Romanized alphabet
in the Communist version of China.
And Taiwan is like, no, this
Romanized pinyin thing is
an invention of the Communist
Party, and a total sell-out
of the Chinese traditional
writing system, no way.
But Taiwan is secretly like,
we loved the idea of
having an alphabet for our
Chinese language
because it made it a lot
easier to teach literacy.
So they adopted an alphabet,
but it's not the pinyin,
Romanized alphabet.
It is an old alphabetic
system that was developed
in the early 1900s.
- It's zhuyin. They did it before pinyin.
They're completely
newly-invented a set of symbols
for this purpose.
- Wow. That is wild.
So because they hated
their Communist enemies,
Taiwan rejected the Romanized
alphabet that Mao was pushing
and stuck with this traditional alphabet
that had been developed
a few years earlier.
And that's still how it is today.
(woman speaking Chinese)
So this gets to a pretty
satisfying answer to the question
of this entire video
which is how do Chinese speakers
type on a qwerty keyboard.
The answer is, if you go to mainland China
you're going to see keyboards like this.
People in mainland China use
this keyboard to type out
the sounds of their words,
and the computer takes that
and renders it into Chinese characters.
If you live in Taiwan,
you'll see a keyboard
that looks more like this,
but you basically do the same thing.
Use these characters to type
out the sounds of the word
and the computer will render
it into a Chinese character.
Both of these are new writing systems
that were developed in the past 100 years
to help Chinese speakers
spell out their words
and move away from a
character-based system.
- [Narrator] Now what are the key features
that you think should
be in an ideal laptop.
- [Woman] Standby for the
software transmission.
Better start your recorder now.
- Okay, back to our timeline here.
It's the '80s and '90s. China
is starting to really adopt
technology and they're
using these typing methods
to use the qwerty keyboards
to actually participate
in the computing world.
But they're still lagging so
far behind the Western world.
They're way slower in their
typing so the Chinese government
went back to the drawing
boards and was like,
how can we make it faster.
And boy, they found a solution in the '80s
that will change everything.
(woman speaking Chinese)
And this is the work that's
kind of juicy, in my opinion.
This is the part that
is like, I don't know,
really helps me to understand
how people type today.
You know when you go to Google
and you start typing a sentence,
and it fills out the rest
of the sentence for you,
or even on Gmail these
days, like I'll be typing
and suddenly it'll like
predict what I want to say.
It's pretty cool. It's not life-changing.
It's sort of like saves
me maybe a couple of
milliseconds every day.
In China, this technology
of predictive text,
predictive typing, was life-changing
because regardless of what method you use
to start building your
characters in the computer,
the computer now starts to guess
what characters you want to type.
For example, let's say someone
is using one of these systems
that we're gonna use to
build these characters,
and they type this character.
This is the root of a Chinese
word and it means "water".
The computer sees this and says,
okay, you just typed "water".
There's a bunch of
characters that are derived
from this root, this "water" root.
For example, here's the one for "river"
or maybe you actually want this one
which is the word for "wash".
So if you just type water,
you can look at these options
and decide which one you want.
This was an algorithmic,
predictive typing system
that was happening in
the late 1980s in China,
three whole decades
before anything similar
surfaced in the West.
And it is this technology
of predictive text
that changed everything for China.
- [Narrator] Before computers,
there was no practical way
to type the thousands of
characters called kanji.
To deal with the complexity
of these symbol words
different systems have been adopted.
- They started to refine
this algorithm to make it
more and more clear that
as soon as you start
typing anything, the algorithm says,
do you want to do this,
or this, or this, or this?
I mean I've been watching a
great deal of competitions,
typing competitions.
(woman speaking Chinese)
This is the thing in China,
and if you zoom in and look
closely at this competition,
you'll see that as soon as
these competitors start typing
a pop-up box comes up, giving them
an algorithmically
generated menu of options
that predicts what they're trying to type.
So typing in Chinese is as
much about choosing from
this predictive menu as it
is about pressing the keys.
It is a combination of both.
And this competition has
pushed developers to make
better and better predictive algorithms
so that people can
communicate very efficiently
using the keyboard.
So how fast are these
people typing right now?
Well, the average English
speaker can type at
around 43 words per minute.
I work on a computer all day
so I'm probably more like
60, 65 words per minute.
There is an English typing
competition in Las Vegas
and the typists here are
mind-blowing 163 words per minute.
But if you head back to these
guys, these people are typing
at a score of 242 words per minute,
four times faster than I can type,
and almost double what
they're typing in English
at the best competition in Las Vegas.
Whoa!
- Wow, that's fast.
- Yeah, it's fast.
- So China used this technology
that was developed in the West
mainly designed for languages
that are very different than Chinese,
and they mastered it, but guess what?
The Chinese government still
has the need for speed.
They're like, how can we make it faster?
So predictive typing in China
went from letting you start
a character and predicting
what character you want to choose,
to then going to seeing
what character you just put
and predicting the next one,
the next word in the sentence
that you want to say.
And now in the last few years
they're pushing it to the next level,
which is Cloud-based predictive texting.
- A cloud?
- Again, the closest thing
we have in the West is like
the Google Auto-complete.
You go to this search engine.
You start typing and the Internet is like,
a lot of people are searching this
so we think you're searching this, too.
But imagine, instead of
just a search engine,
imagine this concept for everywhere.
As you're typing your WORD documents,
as you're texting your mom,
anywhere in the digital
space that is connected
to the Internet is now
feeding you sentences
that they think maybe you want to say
based on an AI-generated
web of information of
what everyone else is texting,
and emailing and writing.
So an example of this,
let's say that there's
a Chinese movie star
that just got into a big car accident.
It's all over the news and
everybody is talking about it.
You've never typed this
movie star's name before
but as soon as you do start typing it
your phone starts talking to the Cloud
and not just the Internet but
other people's text messages.
So then the algorithm says that I think
you probably want to text
about this movie star
and the car accident.
And this seems like a great
time-saving technology
that helps Chinese speakers type.
- It's a good idea.
- But just imagine some scenarios here.
Let's say that you're not writing about
a movie star and the car accident.
But let's say instead you
are texting a friend about
June 4th 1989, Tiananmen Square.
- [Narrator] The noise of gunfire rose
from all over the center of Peking.
- [Narrator] China is a
nation at war with itself.
- There's one major company
that owns the software.
This one company determines most of
what shows up in predictive text.
And in a country where there's
not a lot of hesitation
to control citizens'
access to information,
it's not far-stretched to
see how subtle manipulation
can start to occur with
this Cloud-predictive text.
Algorithm deciding sort
of what should go next.
For example, if you type
in "Taiwan is China",
the algorithm will suggest to you
"Taiwan is an inseparable part of China".
Anyway, this is not a
major problem right now.
And I'm not saying that the
government is manipulating
every individual in China
with predictive text.
All I'm saying is that, the
story of how Chinese speakers
have been able to type
on the qwerty keyboard
is the story of really clever and amazing
technological advancements,
and a huge part of that has
been predictive algorithms.
And all I'm saying is that
algorithmically presented
information can lead to
some dangerous outcomes
in terms of making people
think a certain way.
But at the end of the day, let
us just end on the fact that
China has developed a
really amazing technology
for getting their language
into the computer,
and by doing so,
have been able to pass
any typist in the West,
helping fuel the rise of China
as a technological powerhouse.
(mysterious music)
That's the story here and
I really learned a lot.
Thank you all for watching.
I will see you soon.
And thanks for being here.